My name is Leanne Grayson,
and I come from Wisconsin.
I hope that you will consider me...
Do you have him?
Who?
...as a responsible and moral
guardian for your son.
They've taken Jericho.
Leanne Grayson has been missing
for five days.
Leanne, if you're watching,
please come home.
Why are you looking
so hard for this baby?
We were giving him a loving home.
He was never yours to keep.
If we can find Leanne,
she will lead us to Jericho.
She's not the sweet child
you think she is.
Why haven't you told her
what she did?
A camera?!
We have to protect ourselves.
They have infiltrated our home.
What did they want with us?
You have to understand,
for Jericho,
there is nothing I wouldn't do.
Nothing!
We're hanging on by a thread.
Her presence is an infection,
and it's spreading.
I want to see her get
what she deserves.
We are running out of time.
You'd die to be with him?
I'm his mother.
I don't know why
I keep doing bad things.
Dorothy!
I can feel the dark thing
in me getting bigger.
This is too far.
Nothing is too far.
I hope that you will consider me...
...as a responsible and moral
guardian for your son.